i do remember at one point when i was
first starting to shave my head the back
of my head looked like a nestle crunch
bar
it was so bumpy and so ugly
i promised myself to never allow that to
happen
again hey what's up everybody it's larry
sims here and
these are the easy steps to shave your
head perfectly bald
let's go
i'm definitely perfecting my own method
in terms of
how i shave my head it's smooth it's
easy
it feels super clean and i just love the
feeling of it every time i shave it
[Music]
step one tools and preparations
the most important thing in shaving your
head is to make sure you have
a quality dough razor i like using four
blades in particular
just because i have nicked myself in the
past
and the four blades are controllable for
me i like to also have
my wooden bowl and my shaving cream and
i have
my brush which is really amazing it's
soft it's beautiful
the shaving cream actually is activated
by water
and it's just great it's a dope spot
treatment
for lathering up your head and getting
you prepared to
go for your shave step two
okay now i'm ready to lather up i like
to personally use
my art of shaving shaving cream it has a
creamy consistency
i put
maybe a quarter sized amount in the bowl
get it nice and wet
as you can see i mix it in the bowl
and it goes into a creamy
foamy consistency and
i work it all the way around
i look like cisco right now
step three shaving so what i want to do
with step three
is to start off by replacing
my razor pop the old blade out bam
and you insert your razor handle into
the cartridge
it clicks you pull it out
fresh plate just like that you're good
to go i usually like to switch on my
blades after every five shaves or so
an old blade can hit stubbles of the
hair
and cause breakouts it can accidentally
cut you
you can nick yourself with it it's just
always nicer
and fresh to use a new blade it's an
easier glide on your scalp
and you're just gonna get a closer shave
so now that we're all lathered up
we are going to shave our head with our
four blade razor
with a nice fresh blade i start the
shade
at the very front of my hairline and i
just follow the curve of my head
going from the front all the way down to
the back
to the nape of my neck i like to make
sure that i feel the blade
gray smoothly down all the way
to the back of my neck i've been doing
this for so long at this point i don't
have to use a back mirror
i use minimum pressure what's great
about a
fresh razor is that you don't have to
use a lot of pressure
when you use a lot of pressure that
causes nicks a lot of the time
don't forget to rinse out the excess
cream and hair in your blade to make
sure that your whole head
gets a nice close shave
the biggest difference between shaving
my beard in my head is
i don't take a razor to my face i
usually shave my
beard with clippers and i shave my hair
with a razor
razors tend to break me out especially
around my neck so
the clippers just give me a nice shave
without any of the
backlash from ingrown hairs and bumps
i love a good ball ahead i i think guys
that rock ball
heads you know they they have like a
certain sexiness and confidence that you
have to have like boris kojo he looks
great with the ball ahead
bruce willis looks great with his ball
head another quick tip that i like to do
and another reason why i love
this blade in particular is because
it has this one single blade
on the back of the razor and i like to
go
around my ears
with that blade because it
gets all of those little hairs in those
hard to reach places
another thing that i like to do is to
use
this part of the blade for my crease i
do have
a bit of a crease in the back of my head
and i just take that single blade
and go into the crease to make sure that
i get
all of those little hairs out of there
[Music]
okay so i'm clean i'm shaved and i know
that this
looks like i'm done but this is
only the halfway mark step four
it's the steam towel such a treat
i dampened my towel and put it in the
microwave for two minutes
and now it is ready with all that good
stain
you want to make sure it cools off you
know it's at the right temperature when
it's touchable
i would say a good 30 seconds so now i'm
going to go for it i like to start at
the front
my head and totally just
wrap my head in the towel
feels so good the towel and the steam
heat helps so that you don't have any
ingrown hairs especially
at the back of your neck and look now
yeah
step five finishing touches
let's rock so for my final steps i like
to
seal the deal with an astringent
around the back of my neck just to make
sure
i don't get any of those ugly bumps that
i
absolutely hate and i literally just go
around
my neck around my hair mine
you definitely feel the tingle
astringents are great because they just
come back any ingrown hairs
any excessive dirt or oils
it just keeps everything really super
squeaky clean i don't use it on
my whole head because i don't bump
anywhere it's just really sensitive
usually around the hairlines for guys
especially with using razors
you want to make sure that your
astringent fully air dries before
you go into the next process which is
adding your moisturizer to your head
so at this point i'm fully dry i like to
go in and use my neutrogena oil free
moisturizer
for combination skin the thing that i
love about this moisturizer the most is
that it's
not oily i typically tend to get oily
and shiny
so i like to use products that really
don't weigh my skin down or clog my
pores
it's super light and
it's super sheer which is another thing
that i really love
the last thing you want to do is to feel
heaviness
on a nice clean shaved head you want
everything to feel
light smooth and
fresh here we are now that my skin is
moisturized
i like to use a light pump of
my aftershave bomb i personally like the
art of shaving aftershave
again it's the sandalwood it smells
great
super masculine the two pumps
start at the back of my neck and work my
way forward
i just love the smell of it it's super
light as well
the very last thing i want to do is to
add my spf
yes guys we need to add spf we need skin
protection
i personally like to use my shiseido 50
plus
spf it's really great it's super
protective
especially for me with dark skin i think
that melanin attracts
sun in a different way so i really want
to make sure
that my head is always moisturized i
just use a pea size of it
a little bit goes a long way
slap it on as a final step
and you are good
to go
[Music]
bam
so i hope you found my steps super
informative
doesn't matter if you are balding and
losing your hair
you shouldn't be afraid to commit to a
shaved head
if you regularly shave your head
you know hopefully you found some tips
and tricks and what i've
helped you guys out with or shared with
you that can help you in your grooming
journey if you're thinking about shaving
your head
do not be afraid it's fresh and it's
sexy over here on the ball side
it's like the spot treatment for your
hair guys treat yourself
treat yourself to an experience with
yourself
and your bald head be confident be brave
be assertive stick to it and rock out
your baldness
love it peace